big gay thing welcome back to mild once
the show with mild wings and even milder
question welcome back to the Jenna
Julian podcast this week we're doing
this again mm-hmm we're emulating in the
worst possible way the show hot ones
into our own version as we like to call
it mild ones but the show with mild
wings milder questions and even more
mild production valueee dry wings dry
questions come get dry with us right now
guys this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace make sure you check out
Squarespace by going to Squarespace calm
/in and Julian guys Squarespace is the
what you need to start your own website
they have all the tools they have 24/7
customer support they have all the
templates and functionality that you
might need and it's very easy you don't
need to know a lot you can say maybe
look damn good for not a lot okay check
it out I go the squarespace.com slash
you're doing to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain and give
it a shot also brought to you by the
skin guys the skin is what's waiting for
you in the morning when you wake up and
you need your info the skin has gathered
it all in a nice compact form and sent
it to your email the scheme is it daily
newsletter that says that all the top
stories and bits that's happening in the
world you need to know but in a really
nice email format in a newsletter it's
completely free right now you just go to
the skin that's t hese I and then calm
slash Jenna Julie get started for free
subscribing Lee is love for you don't
even watch owe money when you enter to
win up to a $50 Visa gift card yeah
that's pretty gas check it out
thank you sponsors Thank You sponsees so
well it's really and what have you done
I'm actually really proud of this I did
it I did it more legit this time last
time I kind of threw some stuff together
I ran off to the store
since raging what I thought was my
thought and we did it but this time I
did some homework methane alright so I
have for most of these I have looked up
and researched this zonal level it's
going to hit level so basically a scale
on how hot something is we have seven
sauces
okay so we're ranging from the the
garlic one over here I'll read off the
names of the sauces okay we got Nando's
garlic Perry Perry eight thousand school
okay that's baby it's nothing okay over
here we got deals ready in Texas kicker
right around $8,000 yes I don't know and
then I couldn't find it then over here
we got Nando's hot Perry Perry st. brain
is this but hot twenty five thousand
school events you move on over to the
Arizona gunslinger Chipotle habanero
hundred thousand Scoville units so
that's when this recipe Louisiana I know
then the real two boys over here we have
okay so did this was ordered off of
hedonist which has a website that first
we feast sells their own sauces for a
cultivated group of sauces this is
torchbearer
zombie apocalypse sauce with a whopping
500 that's such a job he did it he did
and I had to do it I got the last time
this is the hot ones signature last ab
sauce okay 1.5 million I'm going to die
scorpion pepper can't we just do like
Frank's extra hot red hot and they call
it
this is mild ones so and that's almond
milk and that's nasty no it's not nasty
it's not nasty
okay so yes oh okay so we're number one
mostly same thing is we're gonna ask
each other questions are we eat wings
ready gendering president
did you do this all the peri-peri garlic
cheers Cheers the same [ __ ] mm-hmm -
Tamar wing-eating
gross Podcast sounds pretty good
inspires you
I told you we're not taking the easy day
that's already spicy that's not spicy
that hurts cuz a thumb I'm gonna die
yeah okay let's start with the questions
what do you got hit me my first question
is what was your first impression of me
when you met me
when I first met you I thought you were
a really cool chick they were really
sweet to me mm-hmm I would observe
because I worked for you King so I would
come to your table from time to time
bringing things for what I got to
observe you seem like a really fun
person to be around
so everyone around you it was like
feeding off your good enemy Oh
again you seemed got my lead though it
was like no way but my first impression
was like that and also you really speak
to them oh I like your mom imon walked
into the bar didn't know you nor did I
really aside from the patron and
bartender relationship well any grown
woman that walks into a bar with the dog
is my best friend true can argue that
I'm sorry but well what was your first
impression of me is that your first
question are you still in my question
I'm stealing your question I have no
questions okay my first impression of
you was that you are so cute like I
thought you were just like the best
looking young man that I had seen in a
very long time but my impression of you
is that
you were a baby like I could never date
you because you were too young and then
once I got to know you I was like your
ear an adult you know but upon looking
at you I was like there's no way he's so
he's a baby so just my looks huh no you
were so funny and so sweet and you are
so nice to me like you always open doors
for me like you just treated me really
respectfully and I would text you like
because we weren't living together when
you're dating obviously now I'll text
you like you know 10 p.m. and I'd say
something like oh just like mister or
whatever I you text me back immediately
which is not something that I was
accustomed to at all I mean like oh I
was started leaving you a message for
like when you woke up or something but
like you would wake up and text me back
I don't like games me how I was just
straight up about things I'm like the
moment I received any interest in you I
was like alright now it's time just do
what you but you guys a lot of guys
don't do that they try and like play it
cool you I would text you something you
would text me back right away because I
wanted to talk to you my first question
though when they you go skin oh I want
to go skiing
why don't you escape I'll go skiing one
time this winter this upcoming winter
I'll go skiing one time if you really
want me to really though yeah but I'm
not like I'm not gonna have a good time
I don't want to go fast
under that condition you'll go scheme
but you promise you won't got their time
yes
you know skiing isn't all about like
fast yes it is not everyone else is
gonna be going faster than there's gonna
pizza down the mountain I don't want to
do it and I'm gonna work myself well I
worked myself
you didn't mean madly pressured me the
skiing if I break my knee in half well
you're like completely foreshadowing it
happen so that's step one I'm like not
what to do I'm skater well I'll finish
my first thing so I just took a bite do
you think anyone move on number do all
right
number two we got DL Jardine's Texas
kicker habanero
cheers Cheers now I'm tasting Tabasco
hmm I feel like the first one was
product yeah me too
which is meaning there was no I feel
like any time you look at my house less
than theirs unknown units it's probably
not that out yeah I should have assumed
that well have a little break into this
one the second one is definitely like
pretty mild that's nice I'll finish this
over them by few what's your question
that's reporting on ago right Julian
yeah
my next question you was what was your
first impression of my dogs when you met
them for the first time I had never seen
a dog well my mom had a Chihuahua mix
still does so I saw marbles I was like I
seen a dog like you but I've never seen
one that small you know I mean I've seen
in several other most people's that
would they see marbles I didn't think he
was that small right kill me was that
small right yeah that was my first I was
like how was he so small my second
thought I was like I want to want to win
him over because he's so clearly
protective over you like I don't want to
get in and I remember that we went for a
walk or something and you had the Cobo
cop like the sling and you you were like
okay you're gonna you're gonna arrive at
Julian put it in the comic up and you
gave me the coke up and I walked and I
just remember him like looking at me
it was just looking at me not like he
his eyes would not leave my face why
were your luck he was just like you sure
about this you shouldn't be and I just I
was like I'm breaking you down and then
I remember filing the moment I took him
out with him was when he was and then
Kermit I remember you telling me that
you always thought Kermit was like too
much like he had no bad well my first
it was with Kermit was he was guilty and
bright but then has to be started dating
in a sudden spend a lot of time with
them yeah absolutely
my my sauce whatever work he doesn't
never leave you alone like that's new
for me for me is like a dog you play
with them and then when you want your
own time they're doing their thing that
was never the case there's no such thing
as a long time Kermit
I was I was genuinely confused why he
wouldn't leave you farm alone he's
literally here right now they're all
right here I haven't walked into a room
alone in years but thanks to Julian's
new system here we have backup audio now
in case it was even like a power out so
we just cut really quick because the
computer wasn't recording but we got a
backup going baby
Oh feels good feels good baby alright
feeling good are you finished oh yeah I
got hungry halfway through so I just
finished which dog is your favorite Oh
Julian I won't tell them oh my god I
can't answer that they're all my
favorite in different ways I won't tell
them I promise really in no ammonia
Ansari not he's sick good question if
you had to write a youtuber book what
would it be what do you mean a youtuber
ebook for me yeah have you had to write
one what would the title of it be and
what would the book babe
I mean I've had that stuff like pitched
to me and they're like you'd be super
easy you can just [ __ ] like we'll
make like a how-to guide of like ratchet
beauty tips and blah blah blah like I
mean maybe some people out there in the
world would genuinely appreciate that
but that is just not it doesn't need to
exist it's like it's in video form it
need to be a bit less of like a
realistic question more of like how
would you make your book sound the most
youtuber II what just I want to hear
your youtuber title youtuber title book
foe youtubers have a book I match a
beach okay how do you spell Beach BAE
ch no T Beach
no Tino said no no chair all right your
Tim only moving on to the next swing how
are you doing you're already sweating I
can I'm sweating because it's hot in
here not because well all right we're
moving on number three Perry Perry this
is the hot Perry Perry okay
we had the regular this one was hot this
is gonna be hotter this is gonna be the
hottest thing we've had so far I'm
sweating in my mouth hurts a little
already Cheers Perry Perry bad bet
that's gross Cheers hmm that one's
delayed what wait
I'm waiting it hits you later I still
feel like the first one was the hottest
uh-huh that's fine that's fine I mean
it's coming in now right it's coming in
now but not the same as the first one
Oh someone's hot this is technically
hotter ask me your question okay do you
like that I wear leggings every day tell
me honest that's my honest thoughts are
I think he looks super cute
and I like grabbing your leg when you
have lighting is on oh no it's like upon
the ground I don't know what your
obsession is with my legs like I know
good like I don't like my life I hate my
life you have good legs well this leads
me to my next point I do like that you
wear leggings all the time but I wish
you would wear shorts more I hate
wearing shorts like anyone out there
tell me your time where I'm are you
wearing shorts like it's very rare and I
look very hot look so cute in shorts oh
my god you look so cute or no gonna have
this long torso and short little legs
like it's not it's not a good look for
me my mom okay no it's not we're not
gonna agree on this but I don't like my
legs I'm correct I'm correct you like my
leg up and you also grab my calf you put
it right up there
you can put it in my face like that do
it like that
don't touch my cap making me
uncomfortable that one wasn't bad that
was a good one yeah was there another
hat mmm Scoville be like we ally in
beach all right
oh it's your turn very question a mild
question please no hot questions only
mild questions on mild ones cardi B
cupcake Alessia car you gotta [ __ ] one
marry one kill one mmm oh that's hard
I'm I'm definitely gonna marry Alessia
Cara
handsome good I don't even know why
she's in that category I just figured I
absolutely marry Alessia Cara
love her it is kind of an odd category
for her okay so you marry a less yet um
I would probably [ __ ] cardi beep and
unfortunately I'll have to kill because
I love cupcakes so much but why are you
killing her if you love her sometimes
you just gotta you got to kill the ones
you love okay that's that honestly no
dark I am I appreciate how brutal you
were with that right there well like I'd
rather marry a less you car out than
cupcake unfortunately that's just so I
feel I love less I think that's a good
choice why what would you do I would
probably do the same thing right yep I
do you same thing yeah mm-hmm good call
all right Julian do you think I have bad
eyebrows no I don't do you think my
eyebrows are aggressively explosive
those are two different questions okay
so the first answer is no you don't that
I rose second answer the internet has
been making fun of my eyebrows for years
well no I think that I think you do have
two weeks I think you do have expressive
eyebrows
an aggressive way but that I don't know
about you but that is attractive to me
anything aggressive like that yeah oh
yeah
I appreciate this attractive oh yeah
ladies I hope you understand that like I
need a man that likes aggressive Viper
anything aggressive that you do it
speaks my language so I like it
Oh Aries language yes just the way I am
uh yet aggressive things so you like
this oh okay well violence is something
else that was aggressive I just slapped
you aggressively on the leg I think I
was so aggressive that was like someone
who's like I'm aggressive about watch
how aggressive okay that was aggressive
so you find that attractive yeah oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah anytime you if you can
picture if you're doing something that
would make him bark it's probably a
thing I like oh my god what what did I
say I don't know you're talking so my
eyebrows being aggressive you like my
eyebrows being aggressive yeah that's
wild as hell I had no idea this is a
little more serious and deep okay what
is something you've always wanted to do
on the Internet
but it's been afraid of what people
might judge you about earth or say about
you doing it um probably something like
a little just more mundane you know like
I did vlog like involvement and stuff
like on my vlog channel but anything
that's just like regular not meant to be
entertaining whatsoever I know people
are always like oh just do whatever you
want but it there is a level of
expectation that people have certainly
for my main channel when you're
uploading a video and you know that 18
million potential people can see it like
there's no part of you that's like yeah
I would love to just upload a vlog of
like what I eat in a day or like you
know the the sort of mundane things that
people upload to the Internet that I
enjoy watching yeah for some reason I
can't fully wrap my head around
being my content you know yeah because I
do feel like as much as the vocal
majority and the comments are like we'd
be happy with whatever you posted it's
not necessarily true you know like I
think people eventually would be like
I'm bored
goodbye yeah I hear you but I do wish
that like there is a level of jealousy
like the grass is always greener on the
other side it's like I wish sometimes I
could just post a video where I'm just
like doing whatever and people would be
like this is great like I feel like I
have a certain amount of leeway for me
to post like the vlog when we were
decorating our house like if I started
uploading that every week I think I
would see my channel sort of just people
being like this is very boring and I
wouldn't blame them because I think it's
boring to because that's my life you
know but I do enjoy consuming that
content it's a super honest answer I
think that like a lot of times when you
are to make a video like that like the
decorating the house video where it's
sort of relaxing it's more of like real
life stuff less less kind of like put
together or dramatic I think you get you
reach a level of satisfaction from that
because it's like wow I shared a piece
of my life and people were we're happy
about it yeah but I also feel like mmm
you know I mean I totally get where
you're coming from where you're like I'm
afraid if I were to do that a lot then
people would maybe lose interest like
that's a really honest answer
yeah but I'm also from you know vlogging
as much as I have which is not a lot
like I hate how much you know when
you're just posting your normal life how
much criticism that opens you up to
that's actually really hurtful you know
like there was a time we were in the car
and I like fed the dogs like rawhides or
something and all the comments are just
like I can't believe you'd feed that to
that like they're young - they're like
that's so bad for your dog and I'm like
[ __ ] man like I'm just a regular person
like I don't have every piece of
information that's the best thing in the
world like I never fed them rawhide so
after that it's really exhausting you
know when you're like that's totally not
the focus of your brain or like what
your day was about and that's all
anything everyone's talking about you're
like wow I feel terrible I feel like
[ __ ] you guys made me feel like a piece
[ __ ] like it opens you up to a lot of
things that you're just like I didn't
need it or want it you know like if you
saw it one time I'd be like sick I won't
feed them rawhides over again but seeing
it a thousand times or getting tweets
about it and then it's not like it ends
there you know people keep watching it
years to come so then you'll still get
tweets about how you shouldn't feed your
stalks rawhides because that person
watched a video from 2013 today and
they're just letting you know you know
like it never ends so that part of it is
not my favorite either you know I mean
that's the other side to the coin of
sharing your life in a candid way which
most of the time is really positive and
it's like what I've done most mostly on
the internet and in a way it's been it's
been great because I feel like I can
laugh about things in my life with a
whole bunch of people on the internet
and they can make jokes about things
that I normally would have just seen as
my wife and that's so cool and magical
but I hear you and like you don't got to
tell me dude
like people people judging your
decisions or the way you'll ever even
the smallest little things in your life
it has it has a lot of power to that and
a lot of people and I would say like 99%
of the people who common things about
you or your decisions or how you conduct
yourself in your life in a vlog 98% of
the people don't mean harm it just comes
off because the you know they're
thinking oh I should let them know
because I'm a fan like they need to know
but they don't put themselves in your
shoes where you're posting videos and
then the whole internet is there judging
everything you do and you're just like
holy [ __ ] dude I can't even do anything
right discouraging yeah so I yeah but I
mean it's also very encouraging it's a
it's a wild roller coaster it is that is
a weird roller coaster you know yeah but
I do I mean I wish like I think about in
the future as I get older like am I
gonna sit around and turn myself into a
chair like if you asked me ten years ago
I was like by the time I'm 30 a minute
he'd done with that the here we are you
know and it genuinely does make me
creatively happy since I've changed my
content to be stuff that I would just
like to do or try or dabble in or
whatever and it doesn't need to be
insane like I don't need to jump out of
a plane like I'm just I'm trying to
make myself into a [ __ ] chair yeah
but I imagine as I get older like it
would be nice and I would find it maybe
a little liberating to just sort of like
have it you know be as close to who I am
in that time you know yeah I mean those
odd cast has done a lot for me it's like
yeah I um I mean challenged to feel this
like I have all these thoughts that I
just want to like talk about or like
yeah now but the only format I have is
this like three-minute bubble of time so
like even if I was feeling a certain way
that's my only outlet but now you know
we have a chance to sit here and just
like just say whatever the [ __ ] you want
I know I was really nice I hear you and
the podcast has done the same for me
like being able to sit here and talking
yep
just like what about whatever yeah
whatever way we want it's like it's a
really nice okay tastic outlet so then
when I went back to my main channel it
was like well here's this is just my fun
time yeah I got on my ranting out on the
podcast or my thoughts whatever I want
to say but I think in the future you
know fun time might change into
something else and that's okay yeah you
know but I do think it would be
liberating to to not feel the pressure
to entertain cuz even on the podcast
it's like a lot less pressure to
entertain like we can sit here and have
a conversation that's really nice yeah I
mean that I share that goal with you
that at whatever point I'm in in my life
I'm able to share a piece of myself you
know honest easy way not easy in the
sense that it's not hard work but easy
in the sense that you're not putting
something on and people will enjoy it
and you could you could exist on the
internet like that it's really nice
I mean moving on yes move on all right
we're on number four we're on the
gunslinger baby Arizona gunslinger to
pull a habanero this puppy is let's
check it
Arizona gunslinger is a hundred thousand
Scoville okay so this one by the way was
twenty five thousand Scoville I missed I
missed that was this is a hundred
thousand so the one we're doing is a
hundred thousand this one was only
twenty five so this is gonna be the
hottest one we've done so far so far
under until we die later a hundred
thousand Arizona gunslinger
I'm not like good at spicy stuff
oh that's we forgot to say how are you
with spicy foods mmm I'm bad I think I
need a little more on this one I don't
so you got a dude you got to do the last
tab right it's not the last doubt though
I know but hey When in Rome do as Sean
Evans does When in Rome do as Sean Evans
does is that it just came out of your
mouth mhm
no it's not too bad okay I guess I don't
understand the Scoville scale or like
how hot a thing I've eaten was 100
thousands not that high yeah yeah well
that one's a million you said right 1.5
what the hell man yeah so work we're
just getting warmed up here oh just like
drooled on myself this is such a nasty
podcast no it's not oh what's your next
question for me oh okay marble are you
all right he's fine he's just walking
around list some of your all-time
favorite baseball players
mine are Nomar Garciaparra Big Papi
David Ortiz Dustin Pedroia and Manny
Ramirez all right that's good question
um and why mm-hmm well let's see I liked
a lot of catchers cuz I was a catcher so
Jason Varitek all right cat love to our
attack
I loved Joe Mauer even though he wasn't
a traditional catcher people would
consider him as a generally a first
baseman or outfielder d-h because he
just he was there for hitting he was
there for his offense but I appreciated
his catching I just kind of liked the
way he carried himself this is a sin as
a Sox fan but I really liked Jorge
Posada who's gonna ask enough yeah I
thought he was such an animal and such a
great catcher and he held that team
together so many times my brother was a
big fan of Nomar even when he was on the
A's I appreciated Nomar to just you know
guilty by association and probably my
favorite baseball player of all time was
David Wright mmm New York Mets third
baseman the one of the beautiful
portrait
that is not amazing who painted it oh
yeah you painted a photo you did
I painted a shitty painting it's not
shitty it's beautiful I loved your art
your art is the best art of all the art
mmm I don't really make any art just
kidding every day I wake up and I make
[ __ ] art okay that one's I was
getting me a little bit yeah it
definitely got a little hot that one's a
hundred thousand so we'll get a nice
little break before the finale the next
one's gonna be a little bit of a break
hey man um what's your term that
question so I know you're not the
biggest office fan but from what you
know of the office what character do you
relate most to and why probably what's
the redheaded lady that has a drinking
problem
Meredith yeah I like Meredith a lot she
seems like just teetering on the edge of
sanity and I like Stanley mm-hmm because
he doesn't put up with [ __ ] and he just
his eye rolls belong in the MoMA what
the [ __ ] this is brilliant I really I
like Dwight a lot because I identify
with the fact that he completely lives
in his own world that makes perfect
sense to him like all of his logic is
flawless to him yeah I don't identify
with Jim whatsoever I think he's a
[ __ ] cocky little [ __ ] whoa
I like Pam I do I think that she's sweet
and they just don't have a problem with
her yeah I like Michael Scott I don't
think he's nearly as funny as everyone
else does I wish I could tell you how
much I'm enjoying this right now I mean
Steve Carell I think is yes all the way
ten but Michael Scott the character I'm
like he's very predictable to me mm-hmm
that's why it doesn't really hit me in
my giggle dick all the time and his
shtick got tired for me well you didn't
follow it through to the end so easy
with what you're saying here but ya know
that's really great assessment of all I
care Gabe wonderful game that attack
Gabriel Susan Lewis
out of ten who else do I know who would
you think I'm the most like because I
know I'm the most like I don't know
Creed I don't know I'm definitely a
Creed he's just met he makes no sense in
anything he ever says and half the time
people aren't even sure likes Creed he's
the old guy oh okay I'm great uh-huh I
want to show you some clips about Tommy
what everybody hates tell me why would
you say I'm like Tobey okay I don't I
was just asking you know what else
everybody hates what getting a constant
at the water cooler because they didn't
have the information from the skin
newsletter that arrives in your email
every morning and you could be that
person too you can get the skin to your
email starting tomorrow
go to this skin calm slash and enjoying
the skin is a newsletter with all the
top news stories and all the top
snippets of what's going on in the world
that you need to know in a really easy
to read way okay it's not jumbled with
nonsense or opinions or editorials it's
literally just the facts it's what you
need to go about your day to be educated
enough to be a wonderful participating
contributing member of society okay and
it's completely free it's an awesome
newsletter okay and it's the best part
is like the way they format it it's it's
like easy for you to get what you need
there's like little facts news story
there a little fact there you're not
reading through you know to go through a
paywall unlike I wouldn't newspapers
website or pick up a magazine or go on
Twitter and sift through you know leave
that for fun okay
get your facts in the morning with the
skin okay it's completely free it's not
a free trial it's free okay you
subscribe by going to this skin calm
that's th es ki mmm calm / Jenna Julian
not only are you getting a free
newsletter to your email every morning
but you're also entered to win a $250
Visa gift card guys you can get all of
what you need in terms of news in the
best most efficient way possible because
it's all about efficiency people all
right go to the skin black arms less
time Julian check it out let some of you
think also guys if you're considering
building a website and you're scared and
you're holding off because you're like
oh man I don't know how to code this is
a scary foreign process I'm probably
just gonna put it off until I can figure
out another time
don't put it off any longer Squarespace
makes it easy they give you all the
tools you need to make the most
beautiful simple customized in your
brain exactly how you imagined it
website that you've always wanted to
create with none of the hassle they have
24 hours a day 7 days a week customer
support the designer templates lets you
do whatever you want with his webpage
you can have an online shop or store you
can create a blog you can create a
full-blown website whatever you want
Squarespace makes it possible for you to
do okay and guys just so you know our
websites on Squarespace so yeah baby all
right
check it out by going to Squarespace
comm / to annejulien okay you can give
it a free trial or you can get 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain when you use that URL you will
not be disappointed you do not need
anything you just go out and figure it
out and they'll help you along the way
even at 3 a.m.
very awesome service Thank You sponsors
thank you sponsors all right I am your
next question my next question huh who
is someone that works on the internet
that you've never met they'd like to
meet I think I know the answer works on
the Internet well you you think I'm
gonna the answer with bending and babish
yeah yeah I mean I I would think he I
would think he'd be a good one I know
there's a few but I'd say that's a safe
bet
it's hard huh oh you put me on the spot
a little bit huh oh good you in spite of
mild words people on the Internet
yeah he's I mean he's someone I've been
watching for long enough to like wanna
meet him or just shake his hand
mhm you know I just I appreciate like I
appreciate what he built off of like
something that was so not on YouTube
prior mean like hiking wasn't on YouTube
prior no I do want to go there how was
how was what he does pry existing prior
on YouTube a cooking no not cooking
cooking exact specific meals from movies
and TV yeah I mean Rosanna pansino has
like nerdy nummies like it's been done
where people recreate know
IIIi would disagree a hundred percent I
think what binging with babish the
channel no what I said was long
you do generalize incompletely why all
right no I agree with you that he has a
niche that he created known you to
that's not what I said all I said was
that he the way he started making videos
if you take a video of his in like in
its completion
every aspect of it was so like together
made it so unique no I agree but you
said nothing it was like that on YouTube
before which I mildly disagree with
because it is mild ones you just want to
disagree with me no I think you just
gotten a meta argument about nothing no
there was no argument you were just oh
okay
Benjamin that that does anyone else know
I'm good alright it's sick what's your
next question are we moving on to this
next week whatever you want let's do it
why do you let Kermit lick you so much
because this one's arrest mm-hmm this
one is literally just like Tabasco
mm-hmm that's right mm-hmm
I let Kermit lick me because he's cute
and it's like if he looks like my leg
like my shin or like my arm like that's
fine once he starts looking like up here
or like my neck or my forehead like
you're done like I don't like any of
that but if he's licking my arm like I'm
really I'm okay with it
he's cute he likes assault only he loves
coconut oil too if I put coconut oil on
my body like forget it he's gonna be
chasing me all day he's a real wicker
mm-hmm like there's a lot of dogs who
like looking but then there's Kermit
mm-hmm and he loves mm-hmm how'd you do
this by the way put him in a ziplock
bags yeah so I marinated them in
individual sauces for a couple hours and
then I baked them this was a nice rest
yeah we need
we're gonna eat dinner after this I
don't know well this is this is the
finale up here so the last two are super
hot right last who were really hot
mm-hmm really like [ __ ] crazy huh
I'm gonna eat this wine and enjoy it
before I die I'm gonna do a dab on each
of them Julian oh my god oh my god
you're gonna die boy okay [ __ ] okay
zombie apocalypse is next 500,000 units
all right oh wait you asked your
question in the future if we had kids
what's one thing your kid could do or be
that would really just test you - become
a cult leader that would just really
[ __ ] piss me off or if they grew up
and hated dogs that would make me really
sad um mine would just be like becoming
a snob of any kind hmm like having or
having any sort of idea that you're
better than someone for any reason
that'd be rough whether or not like you
you know they got it from their friends
or whatever the [ __ ] Irish would not
stand for that a cult leader that's what
your mind went yeah it would really make
me angry and hurt my heart yeah well
it'll probably do the same thing to a
lot of people's families depending on
how successful the command just we had a
kid and they grew up and they're like
you know what I hate is dogs that go
where that I fail you I'm so sorry
yeah I don't think that would happen I
think it's probably impossible what's
one thing you expect even reluctantly so
then I'd be better at than you as a
parent um waking up okay I'll take it
cuz I would though I will be yeah I'll
just [ __ ] knock then I wake you up
every day yeah yeah I'm your alarm clock
also cooking things furiously yeah yeah
you know when you're a little kid and
you're hungry and you feel like the
world's ending and you're just like oh
my god make me something to eat I'm so
hungry like you're old enough to
verbalize it you whipped that should a
bath baby like you're you're gonna be
the one that's like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
and then there's like 12 different
entrees for them to choose from mm-hmm
you're gonna be far better than at that
denying I know I know I know
hey okay I was basically just like
complement me as a future parent mm-hmm
here we go what's on the apocalypse this
is a zombie apocalypse sauce made by a
torchbearer
500,000 scoville units and i add an
extra on top okay it's not like wet with
sauce like you marinated them in it yeah
I made mine white with sauce so this is
really hot that is like it's creeping up
definitely there's a different kind of
heat that the first one I feel like I
ate it and I was like this is spicy as
hell this one's creeping it's making my
whole face hot yeah yeah so my next
question who's your favorite Virgo choco
taco oh I'm so pleased with myself my
dear Virgo is choco taco we just learned
the other day that choco taco is a very
girl and it made me so happy now he
plays video games he's a streamer on
Twitch I like him very much
he's our Internet friend mm-hmm choco
tacos my favorite burger okay I'm
struggling here you shouldn't have done
that that was your fault
you dumped it right on them like it's
hot but I didn't just like jam it in my
mouth I had to do the last tab no that's
this one I'm dying here I'm like hungry
enough that it's very hot but it's not
gonna stop me from eating all right give
me a question okay
I gotta focus on something here ooh here
we go now that our wings are getting
hotter in the aftermath of Tana calm a
poached annicon world can we spill the
piping hot tea that is why no one is
putting any pressure on tannaz manager
Jordan Moroni who was manager since she
was a legal minor for how he has been
managing her or his involvement in Tana
Khan first I'd like to take that
question and claim it because that's
what I've been saying you for weeks not
you that's my opinion that's why I asked
you boy I'm just clarifying for them I
know I've been thinking about that ever
since that story broke from the start of
it all the way till when it blew up in
everyone's faces
that dudes her manager he is her so to
speak Rome he's our you know we Rome is
our Jordan or whatever in no universe
would Jenna or I ever get anywhere close
to involved to something like that
without Rome not only like doing her due
diligence in every inch of that event
but if it were to go south in any way
Rome would have taken the she would have
taken control of things she wouldn't
have just letting things spiral and
where has that dude been I'm sorry but I
don't like I haven't heard a single peep
about him it's just about Michael Weiss
or Tana it's like what the [ __ ] dude
your manager yeah your manager is paid
to protect you and to look out for you
in this world on the internet where
things can go south very fast where are
you right now
I don't get it I don't get why you're
not doing anything for PR I don't know I
understand why you're not investigating
or taking the heat off of your client
yeah this one is don't drink water it's
gonna make it worse
don't look at me like I just hurt you oh
yeah this is hot as [ __ ] dude
my mouth hurts like my gums are my gums
hurt too yeah this one's hurting my gums
you can tap out remember any time I'm
actually uncomfortable yeah that's what
happens is oh oh yeah I'm in like stroke
I'm starting to get over that um that's
just my question
I don't even know the guy of course have
nothing against a person I don't even
know I just don't understand it I don't
understand how you can call yourself a
person's manager and let the world fall
on top of them and not do anything about
it or take control and even if you want
to claim that you are you're not because
in everyone else's eyes like it's just a
numbers as Michael versus the world it's
hit partially his responsibility to make
sure that she's never in a position like
that yeah and she is and now that she is
he's still like I don't know I don't
understand that that's my question is
why is no one given that guy heat so
does he
I ended all right on similar lines my
last question for you my mouth hurts
yeah I still gotta finish this dude it's
getting like bad oh can we talk about
the conspiracy of how now one of Shane's
Tanic on videos made it to the YouTube
training page my thoughts on that is
that it's not even a conspiracy
it's just YouTube's cherry-picking
they're trending [ __ ] like usual I'm not
giving a [ __ ] about Shane like that's
not a conspiracy if if it were someone
who regularly makes the trending Paige
posting those videos and those specific
videos didn't reach the turning page
with the traction they got then I would
think conspiracy but because Shane has
you know consistently been treated like
that by YouTube it doesn't no ordinary
for in my opinion it's just [ __ ] up
yeah it's super [ __ ] up I mean he did
like what 10 million views on each of
them yeah no disrespect to do perfect or
anything okay I've been on that front
page bouncing ping-pong
and I'm just like YouTube's idea of the
YouTube community and the YouTube
community are two totally different
things enough of do perfect I'm sorry Oh
tea okay can they ever do to you um
never mind that um if you could get paid
a dollar for every time I did something
how would you get the richest what would
that thing be mmm
you coughing and or looking at your
phone whoa whoa bring in the heat dude
mm-hmm it is mild ones well I would do
the same for you looking at your phone
you're on your phone a lot too oh yeah
okay can I get breathing no that's not
fair because that's what everyone does
it has to be specific to me okay well I
can't really think or anything so you
want to just get this thing done uh-huh
can you do it I don't know I'm going to
I don't know if I can't you want to do a
DAB no I'm gonna do a dime [ __ ] ah I
know Beach I am a Beach I'm doing the
last time oh my god hold on hold on hold
on hot ones last time baby
no mild ones with mild questions and
even milder answers
don't laugh don't laugh [ __ ] so fun
[ __ ] you why 1.5 million Scoville units
whoa I just feel dizzy
you know I'm gonna admit this I watch
hot ones quite a bit and I remember wipe
your eyes I'm not waiting my eyes and
I'm like I'm like under mass I watch how
long's quite a bit and when I watch them
like suffer I'm like man it's just hot
sauce I never have that reaction I don't
have that reaction now I look like that
person looks like they're in pain ya
know what underneath my eyes burning
them I can't feel my face should've
never bought those Oh Oh God okay yeah I
don't any more questions I have one
what's your favorite fruit I'm pretty
sure it's watermelon my favorite fruit
mango yours is what about you know my
mom can't ask me a question and give me
the answer right after that's how I
asked questions I'm sorry
ah this is uh this one's a beast holy
[ __ ] I need to like jump on the poor
something my head is hot do you beat me
what in eating no I was hungry
mm-hmm it's just some greed okay this is
no [ __ ] joke here nor is this so oh
my god have you tried this it'll help I
don't like milk it's almond milk
oh I don't like milk
okay well this ended well I don't like
almond milk thank you guys for tuning in
to another episode of mild ones our
shitty recreation of the show hot ones
I'm very uncomfortable I'm genuinely
uncomfortable this week we actually did
it right I'm actually suffering right
now like my face is like hot and I
rubbed my napkin on my cheek and now my
cheek is burning I told you not to do
that thank you guys for listening and
watching us suffer and us ask each other
questions going in waves and at times
argue about how binging with babish is
actually creating original content um if
you guys want us to ever do know another
one of these too bad cuz we're not know
we will just know there's a couple ones
well we're in China right now we're in
Hong Kong right now
rather sorry Hong Kong different my bad
we are in Hong Kong right now mmm we are
not here we recorded this in advance
tell us how the future is we would love
to know we'll be back next week with
another podcast help you guys have a
wonderful week don't eat this hot sauce
unless you want us suffer are you okay
I'm good anything in last words be safe
be good water while you're doing these
safety good
[Music]
you
[Music]